did you know Kang the Conqueror AKA
Jonathan Majors was recently booked on
charges of assault harassment and
strangulation and that Ezra Miller aka
DC's The Flash was arrested a few months
ago on burglary charges it seems like
some actors can't help but get into
trouble with the law so I figured I'd
take a closer look at some famous actors
who went to jail or were arrested
Jonathan Majors was arrested Saturday
March 25th for a Litany of pretty
terrible crimes and while we obviously
operate on the time-tested innocent
until proven guilty Mantra the
accusations are still pretty gnarly he's
being charged with harassment assault
and strangulation not exactly
misdemeanors it's a huge blow to what
seemed like the quickest and hottest
career path for an actor in recent years
I mean it seems like almost overnight
Majors went from a talented but unknown
actor to like the biggest thing in
Hollywood Creed 3 Loki quantumania Army
commercials the man has shot up to the
A-list in a seriously fast way and with
good reason he's hella captivating on
screen but this recent arrest might just
be putting all of that to a halt because
certain types of arrests are easier to
sort of brush under the rug and stars
have been known to quickly bounce back
but domestic violence charges that's a
tougher one for fans to be okay with you
know now majors's lawyer has publicly
said that there's video evidence that
exonerates him so maybe this won't
proceed any further than a little bad
press and Majors will continue his path
upwards but if he's convicted of these
crimes things could get drastically
different for this up-and-coming star
things haven't been going much better
for Ezra Miller who's playing the Flash
in an upcoming movie they've also been
having issues with the law of late
Miller who uses they them pronouns was
arrested in Vermont in late 2022 for
burglary charges Miller entered a house
near where they were staying and stole
some bottles of booze they were arrested
for burglary and trespassing but
Miller's lawyer claimed the house
belonged to an old friend of Miller's in
that it was an accepted thing that
Miller was allowed to borrow booze if
necessary but the police didn't see it
that way and still arrested them most of
the charges were eventually dropped
after a plea bargain of trespassing was
agreed upon of course if you've been
following the ups and downs of Miller's
exploits you know that this was only the
most recent of many troubling issues
they've been involved in perhaps most
notable were accusations of grooming a
minor put forth by the parents of a girl
named tokata iron eyes they accused
Miller of quote psychologically
manipulating physically intimidating and
endangering the safety and Welfare of
their daughter that issue appears to be
unresolved so far but I should also note
that Miller sought out psychiatric help
in 2022 to deal with some pretty heavy
issues according to an article in Vanity
Fair Miller has at different times
claimed to be the devil Jesus and the
next Messiah although TBH I think even
if someone is the next Messiah leave
kids alone and don't steal stuff but hey
maybe that's just me I also wonder if
maybe there's something about being a
superhero or super villain that makes
somebody a little more prone to violence
because Anthony Starr one of the leads
of a hit Amazon Prime show the boys was
arrested for assault in March of 2022 in
Spain apparently he forgot in the moment
that he's not actually homelander his
superhero Alter Ego cause while
homelander can get away with pretty much
anything Anthony actor from New Zealand
most definitely cannot star was in Costa
Blanca at a pub when he got into it with
a local Chef apparently Anthony had beef
with the chef named batul aravo and got
violent araujo claimed Anthony who was
quite inebriated punched him in the face
twice which would have been a bad look
already but star upped the ante when he
also smashed a glass on araujo's face
araujo ended up needing four stitches
from the glass when I originally heard
about the arrest I was like well there
goes season four of the boys but star
managed to get off relatively scot-free
he spent a couple nights in a local
Spanish jail and then got a 12-month
suspended sentence he also had to pay
almost 5 500 bucks to arajo though I
imagine that amount gets covered by like
an afternoon of work on a mega hit
Amazon show so it looks like more of the
bloody and hilarious superhero show is
still to come also still to come you
hitting that subscribe button if you
haven't already just saying speaking of
boys will be boys moments Barry Keegan
recently went from being one tenth of a
fairly mediocre Marvel movie apologies
to fans of the eternals to being an
Oscar nominee his turn and the Banshees
have been a Sharon wowed audiences
catapulting him to a major name in the
best but in April of 2022 Barry was
arrested on the north side of Dublin
fortunately it wasn't anything as bad as
what like Jonathan Majors was charged
with Barry was brought to the local
police station after he'd been acting
well intoxicated on the balcony of an
apartment building and while we don't
know exactly whose balcony it was it was
apparently located close to where one of
Aries relative lives so best guess maybe
he was getting drunk with some family
members and decided to do a little
wandering and being loud either way the
Garda the Irish police released him
pretty much immediately after they
brought him to the station sounds like
it was a case of just needing to shut up
for a bit and get some sleep and while
Vince Vaughn's mug shot from his arrest
for assault in 2001 looks like he needs
some serious sleep his mug shot from
2018 is surprisingly festive so I guess
he's learning from his mistakes I don't
know it's probably because his 2018
arrest was a DUI which is not nearly as
bad as being arrested for assault that's
what the star of Wedding Crashers old
school and more was picked up for in 0-1
the DUI happened after he left an
airport bar in California after spending
a few hours there and having a couple
too many but the situation in 2001 was a
lot more serious he was filming the
movie domestic disturbance in Wilmington
North Carolina he and some folks from
the shoot were hanging at a bar called
the fire fly one night after filming but
rather than being excited to have some
movie stars in their local bar some of
the regulars decided that wasn't their
particular cup of tea or shot of whiskey
or whatever so they started insulting
Vaughn and his buddies and things got a
little heated then Vaughn told one
person to step outside with him which as
we all know means a little fisticuffs is
on the way but amazingly it didn't come
to that yet Vaughn used his Gift of Gab
to talk calmly to the guy and they ended
up shaking hands Vince's co-star Steve
Buscemi came out to see what was going
on and a completely different guy
suddenly attacked him with a knife
busemi got slashed on his neck and was
rushed to the emergency room so natural
events tried to come to his friend's Aid
and got in a fight doing it so he ended
up getting arrested for assault
eventually the charges were dropped as
long as Vaughn agreed to not go to bars
in Wilmington ever again so much for
doing the right thing and speaking of
doing the right thing Jane Fonda has
actually been arrested multiple times
over the course of her life and it's
always been for much more positive
reasons most recently she was arrested
in 2019 trying to advocate for stronger
climate change policies while it was
largely like a ceremonial type of arrest
and she didn't spend time Behind Bars it
was actually the fifth time she'd been
arrested in her life besides being a
legendary actress and a fitness Guru
Jane has always been a passionate
protester in the 1960s she was an
activist for the civil rights movement
and a fierce opponent of the Vietnam War
she was famously arrested in 1970 after
returning from Canada because of bags of
pills found in her bag of course the big
problem with that was the pills were
legit vitamins when they arrested her
the police admitted they had done it
because the Nixon White House had
ordered them to yikes speaking of
someone with a lot of arrests on his rap
sheet Shia LaBeouf is a long time member
of the actors gone wild community in
2022 his former GF FKA twigs sued him
for sexual battery and relent less abuse
that case will apparently go to trial in
later 2023 so it's unclear whether or
not Shia will serve jail time in 2018 he
was arrested in Savannah Georgia while
he was there filming the peanut butter
Falcon like a lot of his arrests it
involved him having too much to drink
and getting disorderly and belligerent
during his arrest in Georgia he
apparently also spewed out a tirade of
insults against the arresting officers
some racist slurs and more he got booked
that night for obstruction public
drunkenness and disorderly conduct okay
I'm gonna go check to make sure no
actors have been arrested in the time it
took me to talk about these actors being
arrested you never know right have any
other wild stories of actors heading to
jail or being arrested pop them in the
comments section